JULIA FERRAIOLI: My
name is Julia Ferraioli,
and I'm a developer advocate
with the Google Cloud Platform.
Today I have the privilege to
introduce Ashley Gavin, who's
a curriculum consultant
to schools, non-profits,
and companies with
an intense desire
to teach young people
computer science.
ASHLEY GAVIN: Hi.
Thanks.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
So during CSEdWeek,
we got to hear a little
bit about the Girls
Who Code mission as well as
some of the long-term goals
of the organization.
So what drew you
to Girls Who Code?
ASHLEY GAVIN: It's actually
kind of a funny story.
I left my work at MIT
Lincoln Laboratory
without a job knowing that I
wanted to move back to New York
to write a musical-- so
really completely tangential--
but I got a call
from a friend saying
there was this organization that
was teaching young women how
to code, and they lost
their robotics instructor.
And when I was at Bryn Mawr,
they offered a course teaching
computer science using
personal robots, so I thought,
oh this is a really good
match, and I happened
to have ten robots
in my closet--
as I always do-- and I said,
I can be there next week.
And so I went in, and
learned a little more
about the organization,
and never left.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: That's awesome.
Was having the 10 robots in
your closet a prerequisite?
ASHLEY GAVIN: No.
No, but it's just something
that I always happen to have.
I have more robots than
any one person should,
especially in a closet.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: What
kind of robots are they?
ASHLEY GAVIN: So they're
called Scribbler robots.
You can-- the robot
itself is made
by a company called Parallax.
You can actually
buy them online.
And they have a little chip
developed by Bryn Mawr College
and Georgia Tech specifically
to run certain APIs and such
for educating kids
in computer science.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
That's fantastic.
So curriculum developer,
that's not really a career
that you hear about very
often within technology.
Definitely wasn't
one that I'd ever
heard about when I
graduated with my CS degree.
So tell us a little
bit about what
you do within Girls Who Code.
ASHLEY GAVIN: Yeah,
so when I first
started teaching at Girls Who
Code, the role of curriculum
developer was not something
that I had heard about either.
It sort of formed itself.
My responsibilities vary
on a day-to-day basis.
Some days, I'm helping
teachers with their instruction
in the classroom.
Other days I'm training teachers
on how to give instruction.
Other days I'm writing
code to develop libraries
for making computer
science education easier,
or I'm assessing other
people's libraries.
Other days I'm just writing
a ton of assignments,
thinking of creative
ways to get people
interested in computer
science through things
like art, and
music, and robotics,
app development,
things of that nature.
So it's all over the place.
It's working with people.
It's working alone.
It's really fun.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Sounds like the
perfect combination for someone
who's interests vary
quite a bit as well.
ASHLEY GAVIN:Yeah.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Yeah.
ASHLEY GAVIN: I think so.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Yeah, so
that sounds-- that's awesome.
For those who might be
interested in pursuing
a similar path, can
you tell us a bit
about your background, how you
got to where you are today?
ASHLEY GAVIN: Yeah, so I started
as a typical computer science
major.
I knew I wanted to major
in computer science.
I was lucky enough to be
exposed to computer science
in high school, fortunate
enough that an adviser talked
to me about it.
I had never really thought
of teaching as a career,
but while I was in
college, I loved
being a teaching assistant.
It was my favorite thing.
I worked on a fellowship
where I actually
worked with Bryn Mawr professors
on that Scribbler project
that I described, and when I got
into my later years of college,
I started teaching
middle schoolers,
and I found that all of my
extracurricular activities
were centered around teaching
or advertising computer
science, which probably should
have been a sure sign that I
should do that.
But when I graduated,
I went to MIT,
which was phenomenal
and a great experience,
but I found myself yearning
to be doing more interaction
with people and to be helping
people in a more direct way.
And so that's-- when I found
out about Girls Who Code,
it kind of dawned on me, oh,
maybe you should try doing this
for a living.
You really like it.
And I think it's something that
not a lot of computer science
majors consider while
they're in college.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Definitely not.
It's not a career that
I had ever heard about,
and it sounds almost
kind of similar to what
I do in developer relations
as well, helping people learn
new technologies.
So what kind of role
did science and math
play in your early life?
Do you think that
you were uniquely
suited to go into computer
science once you were exposed?
ASHLEY GAVIN: In some ways, yes.
And in some ways,
absolutely not.
People thought I probably
would have been a train wreck.
So I'll start with the yes.
I played tons of video games
as a kid, which is sometimes
a telltale sign that you might
enjoy making a video game
or making technology.
I was the kind of kid that
built websites for fun.
I loved Photoshop,
but simultaneously,
at the same time, I
was flunking biology
and getting D's in math.
I begged to get out
of math actually.
But I wasn't allowed to
take computer science
at first because of
my poor math grades.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Oh, wow.
ASHLEY GAVIN: Yeah, and
so I think a lot of people
would have said, maybe she could
be a graphic designer or a web
designer, but I don't
think a lot of people
would have said that I'd be
a good computer scientist,
and so finally, when my
adviser in high school
took over the computer
science department
and opened it up to
more kinds of students,
I was lucky enough to
try it, and magically, I
was very good at it,
and my other grades
improved, all the typical signs
of when a student is excelling.
It sort of excels
across the board.
And I just never stopped.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: That's
an amazing story.
What would you say to
other young adults who
maybe think that math isn't
really their strong suit,
but the idea behind
creation and making
that you oftentimes see in
computer science and technology
still appeals to them?
How would you guide them?
ASHLEY GAVIN: Yeah,
I think, I mean,
there's first of all the initial
fear of feeling like you are
not one of those people,
or it's not for you.
And I would say, if you're
the kind of person who
enjoys any art form-- creation
with your hands, with words,
with performance-- I would say
at least consider it and look
at it from the perspective
of building a world.
What kind of world
do you want to build?
Is it a video game world?
Is it an app world?
And that can make it
a lot more appealing.
And at Girls Who Code
we start our first week
entirely building video games.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Oh, wow.
ASHLEY GAVIN: So
just to keep kids
engaged, and they come out
pretty complicated and pretty
fun.
As far as directly actually
going out and learning computer
science, I think you have to
get a little creative in where
you look for resources,
because it can be taught
a little dryly, and I think
that's why people get turned
off, because they're not doing
a full weeklong of video games
as their first assignment.
So I actually would recommend
looking for a game development
course or an app
development course.
Those are probably a good place
to start rather than straight
up computer science.
I think it might be a more
engaging way to learn.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Gotcha, and you actually
had the benefit of working with
robots in some of the intro
classes for computer
science as well.
Would you recommend
that approach
to learning computer
science principles?
ASHLEY GAVIN: Absolutely.
Yeah, in fact, if you're
willing to go out and get
one of these robots or download
the software that-- Can we
provide links at
the end of this?
Is that a--
JULIA FERRAIOLI: We can
put them in the comments.
ASHLEY GAVIN: OK, yeah.
We'll put some in the comments.
I have some links to
open source materials
that you can teach
yourself Python
while using either a
real or simulated robot.
I recommend the real
robot, but not everyone
has $200 to shell
out for a robot.
Or you can borrow one of my
10-- that's not a real offer,
but we'll provide
links, I guess.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Yep, definitely.
Definitely.
So let's dive into a
little bit of the Girls
Who Code aspect
of your role here.
What makes the curriculum
of Girls Who Code different
than a traditional CS education?
You touched a little
bit on this already.
ASHLEY GAVIN:
Yeah, I think there
are two ways to look at it.
There's the actual
content that we teach,
and then there's the process by
which we deliver that content.
In terms of the actual
content that we teach,
it's very similar to
the first two semesters
of college-level
computer science,
except everything's done
through another layer,
and each week that
layer changes.
So, the first week, the
layer is video games.
The second week the
layer is robotics.
The third week, the layer
is art, like graphics--
like Pixar, for
example, sort of thing,
or other 3D animation graphics.
And because we have a
different layer every week,
it's not just appealing
to young women.
It's appealing to anyone
who has an interest in any
of those layers.
So if you're the
kind of person that's
interested in medicine
or mobile applications,
you can find how
computer science
can be interesting to you.
A lot of young women
want to help people.
So a lot of these "layers,"
as I'm calling them,
have to do with helping
people through medicine
or through sort
of social justice,
and that makes it
very "girl" friendly
or, I just think,
human friendly.
I think, without that
layer, it can get dry,
and it's important to have that.
On the other side, I think a lot
of computer science education
right now is sort
of like the way
we learned math 50 years ago.
It's very rote.
And it's more about
syntax and language,
whereas at Girls Who Code
it's very project-based,
and it's very exploratory.
We don't really have a set
curriculum in terms of,
today you're going to
learn about operators,
or today you're going to
learn about [INAUDIBLE].
We kind of find those
topics through our projects,
and the projects are designed
to find those topics,
but the girls will
encounter them on their own
and actually look things up
and learn about them based
on their own initiative,
which makes it a lot more fun.
You go out to learn
something because you
need it to make that
video game work.
It's a lot more interesting
than learning operators
for the sake of
learning operators.
So it's exploratory,
and experimental, and
project-based.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: The
layers definitely
contextualize the lessons,
so that's fantastic.
Have any particular layers
been especially successful
amongst young women?
ASHLEY GAVIN: Yeah,
we do-- I mean,
this might not
come as a surprise,
but the mobile app week
is intensely popular.
Everyone wants to make a mobile
app, and some of these apps
are really, really impressive,
and it sort of brings out
their own interests.
We had some girls make
a mobile application
so that if you don't have
a dollar but you encounter
someone on the street,
a homeless individual,
it automatically pulls
up the-- actually
using the Google Maps API--
it automatically pulls up
the closest soup kitchens and
a list of homeless shelters
and provides directions.
Because a lot of times
homeless individuals,
they'd like to frequent
those locations,
but they don't know
where they are.
They don't have
access to technology,
and so this serves
as a little reminder
that the user can
show this person,
and it has other information.
So really, really
popular mobile apps.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: OK.
So you obviously have a really
interesting role in technology,
helping to inspire others
to follow STEM careers.
Have there been any specific
moments where you thought,
I can't believe that I get
to do this in my day job?
ASHLEY GAVIN: Yeah,
so one comes to mind,
and I just get a
little giggly about it,
because it was just so cool.
Well, two now, but the
first one was we recently
had an article in "The New
York Times" mention us.
Something that
people noticed was
that there is pretty good
gender equality in biology
and forensic sciences,
and we notice
that all of our students
when they come in--
or many, many of our students
when they come in-- they
want to be forensic biologists,
and it's because of CSI.
And so this article
basically wrote,
why is there not a hacking,
coding equivalent of this where
a young woman can watch TV and
see another young woman coding?
And after reading--
some producers of MTV
actually read this article
and reached out to us,
saying that they are producing
a show where-- on MTV--
where a young
woman solves crimes
using computing and
works for the NYPD.
It's called "Eye Candy,"
and they made the pilot,
and it's starring
Victoria Justice.
Probably most developers don't
know who Victoria Justice is,
but ask any 15 year-old
who Victoria Justice is,
and she'll freak out.
And they invited me to teach
the entire cast how to code.
And so I was sitting
with Victoria Justice,
and she signed my robot--
getting a little weird,
but you get-- and yeah,
it was just amazing to--
and the director of "Twilight,"
Catherine Hardwicke,
was there as well.
And so-- she's
directing the show--
and that was pretty
unbelievable.
I couldn't believe that my
computer science degree got me
into the room with these
amazing, creative people,
and it was a pretty cool moment.
My students were obsessed.
They thought it was
the coolest thing.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: That's awesome.
I mean, you've taught basically
people who probably had never
thought they'd learn
how to code how to code
and then got a
signed robot to boot.
ASHLEY GAVIN: Yeah,
I mean, and they
loved-- the great thing about
it was they were awesome at it.
I mean, they were
really good coders,
and I think that speaks
to the creativity piece.
They thought it was
amazing, and they
loved all the
different applications
they could think about
being used on the show.
There's natural-- kind of
related back to my work
at MIT-- there's interesting,
crime-solving abilities
inherent in computer
science that a lot of people
don't know about, including
the cast of the show.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Yeah, definitely.
Well, that's fantastic.
Thank you so much, Ashley, for
joining us today and telling us
a bit about Girls Who Code.
We'll see if we can get
some links to some resources
that you were mentioning
today in the description
of the video.
So thank you so
much for joining us.
ASHLEY GAVIN: Thanks
for having me.
It was a lot of fun.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Thank you for tuning
in to this special edition
of Women Tech Makers.
You can look forward to more
segments coming down the pipe.
To find out more
about Girls Who Code,
visit girlswhocode.com,
and make sure to check out
our previous interview with
Reshma Saujani, founder
of Girls Who Code.